So in many ways, you,
at least for me,
you created
or defined American political satire.
How has that changed?
It feels to me like the
the stuff you did,
you know, the
the showing, the video
and then commenting, it's become it's
everybody does it.
And it's not even
the it's not even comics.
I mean, that's what Tucker Carlson does
when he wants to make his voice.
Sure.
He's his borrowing from your.
Yes. Playbook. Yes.
No, it's it's a real delight knowing oh,
it's always good to arm the most cynical
and worst people in media.
But do you look at it and say,
now this whole thing
has commoditized you?
Well, it was listen, it was commoditized.
You know, I wasn't doing it
out of gracious altruism.
I mean, we were selling Budweiser.
It's always been commoditized.
It was I think it's
you know, there's a lot of talk of.
So exposing absurdity
or exposing hypocrisy. What's the point?
The point is, is that
this is a relentless fight.
They always talk about,
you know, the
the arc of the moral universe is long,
but it bends towards justice,
but it doesn't bend towards justice
by gravity.
Like, you have to bend it.
And there's a bunch of people
trying to bend it back.
And you use every tool in your arsenal,
and none of them will be
you know,
the one thing there is no panacea.
It takes, you know,
all those different things
doing in Washington over
these past few years
gave me a great understanding
of how things actually get done
incrementally and
and sometimes in one fell swoop.
But our country is held together
by hundreds
of really talented legislative aides.
Their bosses many times
are wind up dolls who really don't know.
I mean, half of it, if you go down there,
especially the Senate,
is like an assisted living facility,
like the intramural sports
at the Senate games.
So, you know,
it's held together
by these legislative mates
that are relentlessly trying
to do the right thing
and by the thousands
of grassroots activists
that are trying to get access.
And they're blocked by a mode
of lobby ists and moneyed interests
that prevent
the people in that building
from doing the work that best benefits
all the people outside of that building.
And that's the process.
So you have to use every tool.
You have to permeate that force field.
But presumably the people there
who are Republicans,
who are conservative Republicans,
those aides
think they're doing the right thing
and they're trying
to get across their there.
But they're doing it.
They're honest.
Look, if you can find
honest brokers down there,
you can work with them.
What I'm saying
is that forcefield around
it is made up of not honest brokers,
its moneyed interests, its lobbyists,
its people
who are weaponising misinformation
and disinformation
and all of those form this.
It's the most cloistered.
So you feel you found you could deal
with very conservative Republicans,
force the book
because there was some way
to find common ground
people of good faith.
Now, there were huge
disagreements about certain things.
But when you found someone of good faith,
you could always get something done.